today is not the normal day that we
would do hate mail
but because we have such great hatred
mail for you I didn't want to miss a
week just because I wasn't in studio
yesterday so we're gonna do hatred mail
for you today quick reminder this is
what hatred mail is a fine Rand and
Ronald Reagan had a baby and suckled
that child off the teat of Liberty its
cries would sound a little something
like Patriot man written by Patriots who
hate David Pakman because America
because freedom okay
this hatred mail really doesn't need an
introduction as as is the case with many
of them let's just listen together
anyone ever notice how David Pakman has
all the answers no matter what the
question either he is the smartest Jew
in the world or he is a scripted shill
for the mainstream media even though
David Pakman is always condemning racism
he is probably one of the biggest racist
of all times and he's Hispanics inferior
of always if you only heard it not only
am I not Hispanics but by I guess the
definition of the American census I
would be Hispanic it spelled and I see
KS like the plural of the nickname for
Nicholas Nick very unusual and I've
never really seen anything like this and
I Ellison I know of at least one person
who's more racist than me so to say I'm
the most racist person that can't
possibly be true
yeah the hatred is calling you out for
being racist and yeah that was a racist
sentiment right there yeah I know the
false choice is gotta love all this this
stuff here it's uh it's it's but it's
become a staple really at this point and
I actually sends to some I think there's
it there might be a dog outside today
anybody here that barked I I sense some
level of solidarity with the hatreds in
that we are all together here receiving
on the receiving end of some of the same
tired narratives of homophobia
anti-semitism and racism I don't know I
don't really know how else to say you
know all the answers even though we
started today's show by asking the
audience what our policy should that's
right please tell me I one of the I take
pride in being very willing to admit I
don't have an answer and I think that
that's actually where a lot of the
people on the alt-right seem to be going
completely wrong which is they do
believe that they have all the answers
turn hatred mail into something positive
by giving the hey tree it's a middle
finger by using coupon code hey tree at
40 when you go to sign up for membership
at david pakman.com slash membership you
use the coupon code hey tree at 40 it'll
save you 40 percent which is a beautiful
thing